hey welcome to the Reuben report i'm
dave rubin according to all these papers
in front of me and we have by far the
best show we've ever had in terms of
hair I assure you of that Shana Malcolm
YouTube superstar and Sam Roberts the
man single-handedly taking over Sirius
XM are with me and let's get right to it
all right Congress have you heard of
these clowns they are taking the month
of August off as they do every year
because you know they work so hard for
you all the time they're doing so much
good work constantly that they all
deserve the entire month off because you
get the whole month off don't you right
yeah and let's take a look at the
official website as to why they get the
whole month off by tradition and law
Congress recesses for the month of
August during the Senate's early years
members attempted to adjourn in the
spring before the summers heat and
oppressive humidity overwhelm them and
their small staff blah blah blah blah
blah and then they have to go home this
is a chance for senators to spend time
with their families meet with
constituents in their home states and
catch up on summer reading right yes
because they're so busy all the time
they never see their families their pass
on all these good laws for us and all
that great stuff yeah but basically this
was put in in action originally because
they didn't have air conditioning which
I'm pretty sure they have now so Shauna
you're laughing already is this just the
most respect anything from the
government at this point they get a
month off because of a rating of air
conditioning in 1880 it's a legitimate
problem air conditioned it's hot yeah
it's hot it is hot DC gets humid that is
I've been been so I'll have to take your
word for it but um you know in terms of
is that is it deserved or earned that's
a whole other you know argument as to
whether or not two hundred years ago it
was a good idea I totally get it two
hundred years ago yeah now not so much
yeah uh there are too many things that I
think need work in this country for it
to be it oh it's a great idea for you
get a whole month not to do that but i
think the the you know sticking with
tradition this country does love have a
lot of traditions that we you know kind
of embrace and keep in place and so is
this one
things that we get to keep around even
though it's kind of aren't antiquated
and not of much use to us anymore and
the reasoning behind it is no longer
valid so well you are slightly back in
Congress completely done wow i canno Sam
yeah at what point did grown-up start
getting summer vacation yeah like we're
done with this like the kids get summer
vacation because all they work so hard
in school and everything I knows that's
a joke right you know what I mean it's
like schools not that tough until except
when you're in school then you think it
is then you get out of school and you're
like that was really easy Congress I
mean it was it was pretty easy yeah
Congress taking summer vacation it's
like it's like a goof like it doesn't it
seem like it seems like it's a movie
like they should be going to summer camp
together to learn how to play nice or
something I mean I remember with you
when I first realized that if you don't
vote in Congress you just didn't vote
right he's like oh yeah he wasn't here
for that vote and said they don't even
have to go to work they don't have they
don't have to vote they don't have to go
to work half the time and they don't
they don't read the bill no they're not
doing much I can't believe you're not in
Congress hard about the only thing I'll
say in their defense is even though in
see this is theoretical yeah they're not
always effective at their jobs but what
they are doing their jobs in theory here
they this is a difficult job to do and
so and so okay have you been the
Congress hey hey I can do it in Congress
you know what you are good at that
you're really good at that dude again RJ
yeah you know what I changed my whole
position no hold on I want to go go with
your crazy here I'm just saying that in
theory if they are doing their jobs that
this there is a lot of pressure and if
they are using the time accordingly not
a summer reading yeah I think you're
good with the summer reading it laughter
they all reading Fifty Shades of their
library get out much they have an
audiobook you can just play it in the
car on the way to work you'll be fine
but I think in theory if they are using
time to meet with constituents like it
speaks about if that if the time is
being allocated in that way to really
get in touch with the people you're
representing and making sure that those
needs are being met then in theory it's
not a bad idea but that's not actually
what's gonna happen they're gonna go to
the Hamptons they're gonna go out you
know combos and you know it's all
they're gonna
mactan and great and it's like I thought
you were afraid of AC and the heat why
are you so temp well I think that's
actually legit the theory of what's
going on here versus how because the
other thing is that they needed the
month because a lot of them lived far
away from AC and they had to get on a
horse and buggy I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure John McCain is not riding a
horse backed Arizona so he can be yelled
at in town hall meetings I said we're
living in 2013 where sometimes people
relocate for their jobs and their
families with them I think Congress is
able to pack up their family and move to
DC if they want to be near their family
a lot of congressmen don't want to be
near their family that's why they don't
move that right because their mistresses
are all in dat exactly August is a
terrible month for them if they have to
go home the poor mistresses he have
needs too yeah alright so the last point
on this is there any other profession
that could get away with this kind of
stuff like is there anything else that
everybody doing it could be like no
we're taking the month off doesn't even
matter what might be acting oh my anus
yeah that's true you get you know your
series's off for three months and you
get to ya take at least a month of that
of just I'm resting well there you go
people actors actors and politicians
exactly the same alright perfect okay
let's move on so this I cannot believe
this so so President Obama this week
announced that we're gonna do a review
group designed to assess the nation's
intelligence and surveillance gathering
practices and who did he assign to put
the gang together well he went with
James clapper you may remember James
clapper from this so what I wanted to
see is if you could give me a yes or no
answer to the question does the NSA
collect any type of data at all on
millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans no sir it does not not
wittingly there are cases where they
could inadvertently perhaps collect but
not not wittingly okay I really love
that video because you remember the
episode of Seinfeld when they talked
about how if you're lying the more
you're lying the higher up on your face
you're touching he's literally
scratching his scalp off he scratched on
the top of his head off there so that's
Jay
clapper who is the director of national
intelligence and that him is why there
is he is lying to Congress and to all of
us so of course he's the guy that's
gonna head the group that's gonna watch
dog the thing is this just again I mean
this sort of is like the previous topic
but is this cool can get away with this
but the government I like the idea of an
accidental spy like oh we have all this
information we didn't get our purpose
yeah we like oh look at this we happen
to have it right the word unwittingly
well not only using perhaps you know the
things that are like questionable I ok
so maybe is that what you're saying or
maybe doing this but I got leeches this
guy how does he doesn't it seem like
such a slap in the pit we're gonna take
the guy who just lied to you and you all
know he lied so here we go are you
surprised though because I'm no sadly no
I'm not in the least because I thought
you know it was in 2012 or 2011 there
was that expansion of the Patriot Act
put in place by Obama I thought hmm this
is not an it out in the advent of the
the Snowden and all of this being found
out in terms of hey look you're a big
fat greek me Herman I was gonna say
Greek liar but you're make that like
yeah I agree he's not great ya heard
that play on words doesn't work anymore
yeah but yeah so with the combination of
two things being that Obama's in office
and he's deliberately extended that the
scope and the power of the Patriot Act
yeah and then this being found out i'm
not surprised that you'd put he has a
conflict of interest now that because
the public is aware of it i have to
conduct an investigation well who's
gonna investigate this in the least
beneficial way returning short the guy
that lied to everybody's faces yeah so
does this go to like the problem with
obama sort of is that we all still want
to like him like even the way you just
said that there's this feeling like oh
he plays basketball he seems to kind of
like we'd like you know it immediate and
out with jay-z
and beyond say so we all kind of I like
them so even when he does stuff like
this there's this feeling of like well
can't really be Obama's fault even
though he did it right it's not like you
don't want to admit okay if it's not
Obama's fault then there are people
there just walking all over this guy
that's like this is what we're gonna do
is it the rock Gary part yeah yeah you
know scary but right if he's not in
charge then who is it now we're really
slightly off time in here but it becomes
clear like when this guy's put in charge
the only purpose of this group is for
that guy to say would not you can't say
it like that no that's not information
you can put out there no you're gonna
have to look a little harder like if
anybody actually finds any real
information of wrongdoing that guy is
that the guy who's getting fired yeah is
there to say well I don't not gonna be
on this report yeah nope he's gonna go
well you know wittingly we can't put
that this report those old-fashioned
redacted files where you see everything
is black stout activity hello and the
dates and it's like yeah that's exactly
what's going to be found oh there's
nothing here yeah of course in a
redacted file there's nothing so is that
part of it then that even if they had
chosen someone that was respected that
we already all know the outcome of this
they're not gonna change anything right
i mean Obama was on Leno last week
saying we don't spy on Americans but
pretty much everything that I've seen
since then says the complete reverse and
I think it's you know maybe we don't
want to know maybe it's them assuming
that the American people don't actually
want to know really yeah and if someone
if there was really an impartial if
there was a way to find someone who is
truly a partial who would really delve
into this thoroughly and actually reveal
hey these are the findings it would be
terrifying because it would be like oh
my god you know I know maybe would
create widespread panic and that's the
rationale to just let's just we'll just
put the appearance of we're gonna
investigate but we're gonna make it so
that you're not really expecting an
answer right right I pretty much believe
what you just said that I believe that
to be true that they just have to keep
sort of lying to us at the delay is so
big that they just kinda have to keep
lying otherwise the whole the whole
house of cards falls but is that kind of
sad that America has gotten that sad but
even a best-case scenario yeah you know
that if somebody completely independent
is put in charge and they're like look
at all this stuff we found then whoever
doesn't
want them to find that out we'll be able
to say well look at all this stuff that
we have on you from when we were spying
exactly maybe you don't want to put it
out that is the huge part that nobody is
willing talk about the chill effect of
this whole thing is that everybody has
watched porn right right and not saying
you're watching illegal porn of any kind
but everyone married people are watching
porn without their wife knowing so now
you get this guy duh you know you mean
and then he's gonna be like oh I guess
everything's okay you know it looks fine
or i have this file on you well we have
this file on you naughty nurses 80 I
don't have this file on you yeah it's
exactly man we are truly becoming a
philip k dick novel in this in this
country alright but this is a perfect
segue because Mashable has just come out
with an internet bill of rights I think
this is an absolutely brilliant idea
let's put it up on the screen so they're
sort of using it off of our Bill of
Rights here in the United States if we
still have them i'm pretty sure let's
start at number one the user shall have
the right to access the internet okay
sounds good number to each and every
user shall be offered equal protections
of privacy and free speech regardless of
nationality religion or political
beliefs there's a lot of countries that
wouldn't buy into that one number three
the user shall have the right for his or
her view of the internet to be
uncensored and unrestricted again a lot
of countries not happy about that the
user has the freedom to choose a control
with whom he or she shares his or her
activity or personal information
furthermore data that a user uploads to
an online service shall not be shared
with other users except that their
consent I think they will call that the
Facebook rule number five the user has
the right to his or her original content
works and information she uploads or
produces for the Internet instagrams not
going to be happy about that the user
shall have the right to terminate his or
her participation with any online
service at any time if a user wants to
terminate a relationship with a
web-based service the user the user
shall have the right to delete his or
her user data from said service it's
onwards 7 the users online data and
personal communications including but
not limited to email instant messaging
social media audio video conferences
shall have the same legal protections as
a user's traditional letters phone calls
and any other physical correspondents
are
records gmail actually just won a
lawsuit saying the complete reverse of
that this week number eight no entity
government law enforcement agent
corporation or human may collect
examines steal or otherwise utilize a
user's data without the permission of
the user borrowing legally justified
data collection search and seizure a
pretty sure james clapper wouldn't be on
board that one number nine the user
shall have the right to remain anonymous
online and shall only reveal his or her
identity to whom they choose the YouTube
commenters definitely are going to be
happy with that one right I had number
ten the user shall have the right to use
the internet without his or her activity
or communications being monitored by any
government or agency and pretty much
every government to our agency is
watching us now so nobody's going to be
happy with that okay so I want to start
with you on this one because you're a
big youtuber you put a ton of stuff out
online you guys both do do you think
something like this is is necessary
first necessary I definitely think there
needs to be rights that are clarified
and and because this is the Wild West in
term the internet the digital space is
something that is being taken advantage
of by so many people and so rapidly and
the growth was so much more rapid than
anyone anticipated so much so that now
you know we're just now trying to play
catch-up in terms of what the rules are
so I think there definitely needs to be
something put in place this particular
bill of rights is very idealistic and I
love it I love it yeah Jerry yeah in
theory I think it's brilliant but I the
theory I love the theories but I you
know I can see the holes in it already
you know I think anonymity in the face
of ownership is something that's a
little bit you know I'm not sure how you
gonna play those two cards at the same
time if I you know I don't wanna hey if
hey yo Shana became a persona and Shana
Malcolm's name was no we're affiliated
with it and someone wants to repost my
content how do i how does the logistics
of that get executed so there's some of
these things that are a little
questionable I love that it reaffirms
rights i think the the United were the
United Nations in 97 said that internet
was a basic right for everybody so I
like that they reaffirm certain things I
do think there should be you know
unrestricted use of the internet but I
do think there are things like the
patriot act
in place and you know it's a little
unrealistic to think that you're going
to be able to watch and do and use
anything on the internet without some
kind of monitoring and I do love that it
goes out goes clearly to say you no
matter what nation and race and all of
it that's great in theory yeah but you
know there's the argument of the
violation of some of my personal rights
to ensure my safety which is what they
keep you know shoveling that you know
shoveling down our throats they say that
all the time but at the same time if
someone says to me hey this could have
been avoided if you had allowed us to go
into this person's whatever it is a
months ago and that's why you know
you've lost a leg you know horrible
accident oh crap right you've given me a
lot of stuff to work well no no that was
great so it is part of the problem here
which I think Shawn is addressing that
we got all this stuff too soon we didn't
even know what this was you know what I
mean we all jumped on facebook without
really understanding that we were the
product our brains and all the
information we put out there is the
product which is why they give it to us
for free and now we've just sort of lost
control of this like digital beast yeah
I think so and I also think that if
people don't like it when it spelled out
exactly what facebook exactly what gmail
exactly what these places are doing yeah
but they don't stop using them you know
what I mean like gmail has made it very
clear we are going through your emails
yeah we're looking for keywords and
we're targeting advertisers to you based
on your private emails yeah but people
are like yeah but it's like eight gigs
so I mean just keeps going Your Honor be
the number keeps getting higher I'm like
Facebook's like yeah we're gonna share
your pictures and we're gonna share this
we're gonna store all this we're gonna
give that to advertisers yeah then
everybody goes well what about not gonna
have a Facebook page no I mean yeah do
you think partly it's because it's not a
physical thing so we just keep clicking
yes on all these long agreement and it's
like you don't have something to really
sit there nobody Scrolls down the itunes
thing to Congress I could reading all
those bills there in paper like after
you had a 14-page contract in front of
you you're not reading it you're like
this is okay right paper contract I am
by 40 page I read every single
hey however you're absolutely right i
think it's because it's digital right
you scroll down and we hit I acknowledge
whatever it is and it's not a signature
so it's like it's fine i just need to go
on to the next page yeah cuz it you know
when instagrams policies became public
and i was like literally people were
upset about it but when they thought it
when they look back there weren't any
changes really what did it always been
right here just went public it just went
public and you're you're doing what
we've been doing this what are you
talking about why your existing that I
signed up for I can't believe represent
you with this 14 page thing and you're
like yeah but everybody's on Instagram
right so how could it be bad yeah like
yes you know it's funny when they have
the the one that you actually have to
scroll down a little bit to get the
button just to light up so you can say
except because they know that people
were just hitting except when they were
like oh well we'll make them scroll down
a little cuz that's and you should
they're going like I can't believe I
have to scroll through this all right
well that we plow through that one quick
but yeah there's a lot of crazy digital
stuff out there and you got to be
somewhat aware who does we'll see if
this thing happens all right uh you know
I have a rule that especially on Twitter
I do not tweet or talk about the
Kardashians but this story is so idiotic
that I felt it warranted me breaking my
own rule so Kim and Kanye which is Kimye
or is it it's Kimye and their and their
child north they have aidan they have a
new car and it is a 1 million dollar
bomb and bulletproof vehicle that is a
take off of what president obama uses
let's let's take a look at this thing so
that is uh that is what it's going to
look like this thing is literally a
million dollars it has ever it is I mean
some of this stuff is just completely
insane it has whale penis skin
upholstery if it wasn't clear their
whale penis skin upholstery which is the
best yeah I don't you have that I do
whale penises does it take to upholster
a car oh I to your project
I think it does i think it does the
whole car with two like it's a killer
whale penis you could probably do like
work hard yeah it also has
jewel-encrusted snake ornament right so
let's throw up the cartoon of the second
car they're getting which is the actual
mock-up of Obama's car and here you go
there's Obama sitting he he posed for
that actually and he's very you know you
can see this is not going to have the
whale skin penis interior yet exactly
but yeah and it's a million dollars it's
going to withstand bombs and bullets and
all this crazy stuff what is the point
of becoming a celebrity if you have to
have a bomb-proof car I was my mind
about this whole thing it's like at
least Kanye West has said some political
things that have gotten some people mad
can you imagine being Kim Kardashian and
saying I don't do anything and that
makes people so mad I think they might
throw bombs at my child right exactly
well there's a ton of hate for the two
of them and I think some of it is
warranted in the way the Kardashians
want the money and have just put this
awful thing on us and you know obviously
Kanye has done a lot of controversial
stuff but like having a drive around and
about is or is this that they want the
ideas exactly what I was going to say I
personally I would say they and that's
an unfair generalization to include
Kanye in this but he's now affiliated
with Kim so much so that they're just
you know Kimmy a yeah but Kim Kardashian
has made a career of her relevance being
about people talking about her yeah and
you have to say current well I was
pregnant and then I you know I did okay
I did a sex tape and that made me famous
enough to do a reality show and then I
had to sell off my wedding pictures and
my wedding gotten ended my marriage
ended two seconds later and then I oh I
need to get pregnant now so I'm going to
be affiliated with this guy and no the
baby's here and I'm gonna give you a
ridiculous name so that people are still
talking about me what does she do now
what's next so do you think okay so that
I think is the interesting part is do
you think that they actually sit down
and they're like what can we do now to
get back in oh let's get a bomb-proof
car because those Schmucks at HuffPost
are going to post
and all these idiots like me are going
to talk about it is that is it really
that calculated I don't I think that
they sit there going what can we do next
I don't know that they actually asked
that question but Kanye probably thinks
highly of himself and you may not want
to put him in in the category of Kim
Kardashian but you also know that whale
penis skin was his idea nobody loves his
fabrics yeah but uh he's sitting there
and he's going you know what we should
get a bomb-proof car yeah he thinks very
highly of himself and Kim's like yeah
that's a great idea and then her mom
comes out like a little gremlin from
around the corner like yes yes exactly
and then they that's when they start
thinking of how ridiculous can we make
this car to get it up to get that attend
yeah you know everything we were talking
to on the show a couple weeks ago about
how when the Royal baby was born I was
saying how I actually think that America
not that we need a royal family but I
think England gets something sort of
healthy out by having a royal family
that we may we want obama to be
everything where they get it out a
little bit with the royal family and
then their politicians can actually do
politics are we getting royal family is
like like are we getting some of that
stuff out where we treat people like Kim
and Kanye like the royal family at this
point please God tell me you're not
saying and Kanye would be the equivalent
of our well you're the American version
of it sadly I think okay next plane to
Jamaica leaving like I'm out yeah trust
me this is not what I want this is just
sort of the State of America that we
have this like equivalent of the royal
family like these people and not just
them there's others too and America's
accepted it i mean who's on the cover of
all the British tabloids is the royal
family who's on the cover of all we
American tabloids it's Kimye yeah you
know what I mean and I mean you're
shocked and appalled I know what I would
it's the American royal family anybody
but am I anybody yeah I've got you drunk
alcoholic murderers like the Kennedys
maybe or bushes idiots okay Sam all
right well I promise you I am gonna not
talk about that anymore i broke my own
rule here and we'll we'll see what
happens all right pole dancing people
its back it never left i guess and
organizers of the world pole sports
championships want to reform pole
dancing
to make it respectable enough to be in
the Olympics now I'm pretty sure you're
familiar with what pole dancing is but
here's a slightly cleaned up version
that could end up in the Summer Games
one of these days people think so many
different things yeah it's changed when
I started 10 years ago I'd speak to
someone in there and I'd stay on you
know I teach pole and the first thing
they would say oh you're going to dance
for me at the World Championships for
full sports in London athletes from 10
years old to over 60 are here to compete
and change attitudes like gymnastics
competitions the emphasis here on levels
of technical difficulty and flawless
execution no sex appeal ok that
obviously does take some level of
athletic skill and the Olympics has done
some odd things lately they've gotten
rid of wrestling they've gotten rid of
baseball so there might be room for pole
dancing as crazy as that sounds is this
is pole dancing an Olympic sport do you
will you get on a pole and train for
2020 I've been on a pole and I would
represent this great nation no one wants
to see that good now I do think there is
as you've said a certain level of
athleticism that is required of this you
know I've I've seen many a pole dancer
on many a continent I'm just saying yeah
and they work hard for that money they
uh you know I do think however that they
have to take away a certain I won't see
an essential part of pole dancing is the
sexuality or the sensuality of it yeah
but they are kind of trying to strip
that up strip that away pun intended I
think you to make this more a
respectable sport yeah and so even
though there is the athleticism there's
the argument that Tim if you have to
change so much of its very nature to let
people perceive it in this light you may
not work do you have to totally d sexify
it to make it work because we have
plenty of thing you know you look at
women's tennis it's so based in they
it's all the pretty women that everyone
seems to care about right we should if
you have to do that version of pole
dancing yeah there's you said 10 year
olds right
Paul univ 10 year old yoga I'm just
saying anything that's young for them
young age for the pole yes put it out
but I think I mean there are so many
stupid Olympic sports there's no reason
to sit like there are just as many
sports in the Olympics that are that are
dumber than pole dancing I totally been
archery is like what Archery's hard I've
done archery thinks there's gin pole
dancing she's doing archery what else do
you knew lots of then the list is long
and distinguished or it actually not
that distinguished but pole dancing
there's like a future to it like after
they like with archery once the Olympics
are over what are you gonna go Archer
somewhere else hears use a bow and arrow
to get out you would meet you you're
killing deer you have a venison for
dinner so you all right you did you
literally York City you don't know what
people are doing zombie apocalypse
you'll be you'll be wanting to hang out
with me and my buddies will be able to
distract the zombies there's what's that
guy's name from walking dead if he
didn't know how to use that bow and
arrow would he have been able to do all
that he's done to true I think I might
have been a fictional portrayal but i'm
not sure is that fiction but Paul
dancers have some place where they can
work after the Olympics they can make a
living for themselves yeah it should be
extremely it should be the other way
around it should be a way to get the
ladies off the pole in the clubs is to
say hey if you train hard right you
could represent your great nation but
isn't that ironic though because the
girls that are doing this in the clubs
and in the strip clubs that are giving
lap dances a lot of them are putting
themselves through college they're
actually making a lot of money I think
it's very empowering for women actually
while the people that are doing Olympic
stuff you know they're not getting paid
and there's all these stories about how
all these people win Olympic gold and
then come home and there and they're
broke and don't know what to do with
their life and you want to talk about
endorsement deals can you imagine when
the hustler club gets to put on their
marquee that a gold medalist pole dancer
is dancing tonight yeah there's a lot of
money to be made of that people would
pay cover for that yeah you would pay
cover wouldn't you yeah what yeah I pay
cover for whatever my [ __ ] baby fat and
um you know on those jeans and they
could like clap their butts with it hey
there's so many more uses I die I'm
endorsing this vid for the Olympics
absolutely would finally oh my god
advertise on all in big score
love it all right well I'm pretty sure I
know what Shaun is next yeah youtube
video will be all right okay we got one
more so Queen Latifah is getting a talk
show pretty much everyone has a talk
show if you don't have a talk show
you're okay so queenless he was getting
a talk to and she is already announced
that she is not going to talk about her
personal life and her sexuality which is
kind of curious considering that's what
most talk-show hosts do this is very
similar to when Anderson Cooper got his
talk show was about a year and a half
ago and wasn't going to talk about his
personal life eventually came out now
first off I am NOT I know nothing
private I am not privy to any secret
lesbian information so I'm not
announcing here that Queen Latifah is a
lesbian but it seems to be standard
knowledge that gleam of Davis lesbian
which makes no difference to me I think
it would be great if she came out if she
doesn't come out that's fine too but the
idea that you're going to be a public
figure at this point in 2013 with all
the way gay rights have moved forward
and gay marriage and all that it just it
almost seems like she doesn't deserve it
I don't want to be that judgmental and
as a gay person especially I want to
give her the benefit of the doubt here
but I see this as just a really terrible
sign of how to go about doing public
stuff how's that i also just think it's
highly problematic I think that part of
one of the main reasons that it's a tool
that we see in in terms of interview
style you know and daytime shows and
talk shows it's because it's a way of
putting your guests at ease so if you're
I'm sitting here and I'm talking about
yeah you know I just had my baby and my
husband and I Cora you're like okay yeah
that's that's is that so ami you know
you're here to promote your your movie
yeah it's about you know how this
romantic comedy of me falling in love
for the first time and it's really super
awkward yeah yeah yeah you're right that
would be awkward you know everything is
an awkward segue to something else
because you won't allow that kind of a
report to that naturally would flows in
conversation yeah and I also think
because she started out in entertainment
it's a it's very different when you
start out as like an Oprah Winfrey right
we started out as a reporter so on this
side of things where it's a little bit
more detached yes but you're starting
out as an entertainer and i think that's
that's part of the drawn the
comfortability and is
they should know you they should know
you and feel like they can talk to you
and you can you know yeah talk to them
yeah the whole point of giving a person
a talk show like it's not like Queen
Latifah sitting there going well I'm a
I'm a singer so I don't talk about my
personal life I sing I'm an actress I
act I don't talk I talk like it's the
Queen Latifah show what are you doing a
show for it right and to announce to go
ahead and announce before no here's the
topic I'm not gonna talk about the one
thing that actually everyone wants right
is the one thing I'm not gonna talk
about but giving her a little bit of
leash here is it is it unfair of us to
ask this of gay people and i'm really
only playing devil's advocate here
because obviously i I've put myself out
there in that regard so I don't agree
with it personally but is there some
unfair aspect that we demand her to be
or public people to be totally open
about who they are personally I think
that where we are it's 2013 and we're
living in a space and in a time that is
the most accepting and the most
embracing of homosexuals in media then
it's ever been and I think she's at a
particularly powerful position in terms
of her career it's not as though she's a
newbie who may be afraid that oh my god
I won't work after this if anyone finds
out or what your queen latifah I
couldn't take a job from you know only
good would come of it like only things
that would help other people and people
watching her being like oh she was
strong enough to do that actually do
that and why don't we learn from history
it drove Rosie insane literally insane
that she had to go on and pretend to be
in love with Tom Cruise and throw Koosh
balls at the audience and not be herself
on the Rosie show right and I've talked
about this with Rosie I mean come after
she came out I mean look her career took
off again and she was back on the view
she had a stroll in serious for a while
and now she's a mother again like it's
saved her life people like when people
are being themselves yeah and you are
gonna isolate some of the audience and
say it's a little more polarizing so it
might be a little riskier yeah but
people like it when people are
themselves yeah I don't even know if it
would be polarizing you look at someone
like Ellen DeGeneres any my poor she's a
cover girl as his queen latifah right
isn't
actually Queen Latifah again if she is a
lesbian so stupid but if she's living
isn't she the one that's actually
causing the polarization now because
nobody can not only does nobody care but
I know this from talking about this of
all time I can't wait till the day comes
that I never have to talk about another
gay rights issue when everything is
completely equal and everyone's out or
not or who they are that's it and we
never have to lose again it's exhausting
for me I'm sure as straight people it
must be exhausting for you guys Queen
Latifah coming out would be that classic
case of somebody coming out be like this
is my announcement and everybody going
see no yeah we knew like yeah obviously
right right right you know and it's not
we still think the same there's no
nothing queen latifah still clean with
you and it's also problematic I think
from the perspective of you want people
to invite you to into their homes every
day you want people to turn to tune in
turn on that channel and make sure to
watch you at three o'clock on whatever
you know whatever her time thing is I
think it's a daytime show yeah um and I
think part of that it's it's some
similar to the YouTube space of they
need to feel like they know you yeah
yeah and the fact that you went ahead
and announced preemptively I'm not gonna
allow you to get to know me right you
made a pre-emptive strike that's right
alright so final thought on this because
we all we all are in the world of
talking and entertaining and all that
kind of stuff how much of yourself do
you feel is legit to kind of hold back
for it for your audience and for your
your public I think rizona part of being
a public figure and asking people to
treat you as such like I want you to
make it so that I can make a living just
being myself and I just get to be me and
you just watch me is you are completely
open about yourself and and I've brought
my wife unwillingly into the spotlight
yeah but she's had secrets about her put
on the air that she didn't like and I've
had every piece of information possibly
about me that I can think of oh this is
funny this could entertain somebody
throw it out there yeah um yeah I think
it's it's disrespectful to your audience
to not just completely if you're gonna
be a public figure beep public yeah and
it's so funny because that's to me the
secret of Howard Stern success and most
successful people is just be
honest about who you are and that kind
of thing what about you because you play
you play a lot of characters also but
there's still truth in there is still in
there is an essence of truth I mean my
channel is a lot more outrageous than I
being right now but that's an aspect of
my personality i do say crazies dozen
times like you know just because it's
it's you know comic relief and I'm a
silly person but I can have an
intellectual conversation as well and
there are aspects of my channel that
show that I do think just playing a
little bit of devil's advocate that
whether or not you're a public figure
you do want some amount of personal
space and that but as a public figure
that personal space is smaller yeah and
you are saying i'm not going to expect
the same level you know said I not
telephoto lenses through your blinds
into your bedroom but you know so
there's still a certain amount of okay I
know what I'm out and about people may
come up and say I want a picture or I
want it you know that's a part of that
part and parcel but there is still a
sense of if you want me to feel like I
can relate to you there has to be
communication happening there has to be
a sense of I can share that you know if
I can come on your show and talk about
these things it's because you made that
a safe space and part of that is that
you've made that topic or whatever it is
open and safe and I can just be myself
and share that with you and you have to
do the same so I think there's a
responsibility there alright well I hope
we made this open and safe and you felt
that you could beat you while you were
watching Shana Malcolm Sam Roberts their
twitters are down there you can find
them on youtube and we'll put all that
stuff down there and there is a
subscribe button which they yell at me
every week you have to tell people to
subscribe you just have to click it once
and then that's it it's a very very
simple thank you guys for watching and
we'll do it again
you